[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 hoy los llevaremos a
montenegro la construcción de una
autopista que inició en 2014 para abrir
la nación balcánica no ha podido ser
terminada y la entrega tiene ya dos años
de retraso con sus altos costos
ambientales y financieros más de mil
millones de dólares este faraónico
proyecto ha aumentado peligrosamente la
deuda del país de seiscientos mil
habitantes el trabajo está siendo
financiado por un banco chino y en gran
parte realizado por una empresa estatal
china y una firma local cercana al
gobierno de milo djukanovic que firmó el
acuerdo si montenegro incumple con su
préstamo el contrato estipula que el
país debe renunciar a la soberanía sobre
ciertas partes de su territorio esta
carga sobre el nuevo gobierno del país
ha agravado las fuertes sospechas de
corrupción en torno a la obra el
proyecto de la autopista es parte de la
nueva ruta de la seda un ambicioso
proyecto de inversión e infraestructura
en el extranjero iniciada por beijing en
2013 a continuación el reportaje de los
enviados especiales clyde para calling y
david silver
[Música]
esta es la primera autopista de
montenegro un proyecto faraónico de más
de 1000 millones de dólares para este
pequeño país de 600 mil habitantes
su construcción ha destrozado el medio
ambiente y ha aumentado la deuda
nacional
entonces qué sentido tenía que
montenegro se enmarcará en esta aventura
cochina
hasta ahora había que tomar esta
carretera extremadamente sinuosa para
llegar al norte del país desde la
capital y corista
es muy estrecha a las rocas ocupan parte
de la carretera y los grandes camiones
tienen que cambiar de carril para
evitarlas
lo cual provoca muchos accidentes todos
los demás países tienen autopistas y eso
significa mucho para nosotros
[Música]
inicialmente el país quería construir
una ruta de 165 kilómetros que uniera el
puerto de bar en el adriático al sur con
la frontera serbia al norte pero en 2014
el gobierno montenegrino firmó un
contrato por sólo un tramo de 42
kilómetros en el corazón del país en la
zona con la topografía más complicada la
empresa estatal china cnpc china road
and bridge corporation se encarga de la
construcción
durante al menos unos años más la
autopista se detiene aquí
el pueblo de mate llegó y su puñado de
habitantes
hoy no hay muchas papas buenas
dos ayer botamos todas las malas
peris a vuskovic policía pensionado vio
inicialmente con buenos ojos la
proximidad de su casa a la autopista
pero el sueño se convirtió en una
pesadilla
en su ausencia montañas de escombros
procedentes de la excavación de los
túneles fueron vertidos en sus campos
los chinos pusieron los residuos desde
allí hasta los árboles frutales
era así de alto pero cuando protestamos
los trasladaron
y luego tuvimos aún más problemas porque
trajeron una gran cantidad de tierra de
tan mala calidad que mi mujer y yo
tuvimos que quitar toneladas de piedras
para poder plantar de nuevo
miren todas estas piedras ya ni siquiera
podemos cultivar remolacha
pero esa presentó dos denuncias contra
la empresa china
[Música]
a unas decenas de metros de su casa otra
víctima de las obras de la autopista el
río tara
es terrible lo que está pasando aquí
[Música]
se ha construido un intercambiador en el
lecho del río patrimonio mundial de la
unesco
[Música]
este es el lugar donde el impacto en el
río tara ha sido mayor
y el puente va directamente sobre el río
y para construirlo tuvieron que cambiar
el causa
de river
estas piedras están cubiertas de cemento
[Música]
una infracción medioambiental de la que
en la de ulises bitch dice que no era
consciente el ingeniero encargado del
diseño del trazado de la autopista desde
2008 preside la comisión de control de
todos los documentos relacionados con la
obra
y especifica que este lugar en
particular donde se destruyó el río tara
no formaba parte de mi plan está a unos
cientos de metros de la zona
con tractor y supongo que el contratista
se pasó de la raya
seguro tuvieron que almacenar equipos
instalar vertederos que no estaban en
mis planes que no fueron revisados ni
aprobados
la información había sido transmitida a
las autoridades de podgorica por un
consorcio franco italiano encargado de
controlar la obra
el ingeniero observó durante su visita
que el lavado de las hormigoneras se
realizaba in situ y que el limo del
cemento se vertía en la cuenca del río
tara
básicamente estos documentos demuestran
que el gobierno sabía todo el tiempo que
se revé se estaba dañando e incluso
devastando el río lanzar trabaja para la
ong mans que investiga la corrupción y
la delincuencia organizada en montenegro
para obtener estos documentos que se han
mantenido en secreto durante varios años
tuvo que esperar al cambio de gobierno
en 2020 las elecciones parlamentarias
ponen fin a 30 años de hegemonía del dps
el partido democrático de los
socialistas del presidente milo
djukanovic inicialmente prorruso luego
se orientó hacia occidente miembro de la
otan desde 2017 el país es ahora
candidato para entrar a la unión europea
por tanto era natural que montenegro
buscará socios occidentales a finales de
la década de 2000 para construir la
autopista consultoras francesas y
británicas estudiaron el asunto
no sé criticó la idea de la autopista en
sí sino la viabilidad del proyecto pero
el gobierno anterior ocultó estos
estudios e hizo un trato con los chinos
baines documentos ignorados por el
anterior gobierno pero también hombres
marginados
siempre ha sido un buen lugar aquí antes
de todo este caos
[Música]
estos pescadores con mosca fueron los
encargados de vigilar el río tara hasta
2018 cuando fueron retirados por las
autoridades en un momento en que vieron
que las cosas cambiaban drásticamente
el 90% de la población del río fue
destruida durante estos trabajos durante
dos años hubo barro en el río los peces
no pudieron sobrevivir
los que no lo hay
espero que algún día alguien tenga que
rendir cuentas por lo que ha hecho
en 2014 el gobierno montenegrino firmó
dos contratos con china la empresa
estatal china cnpc china road and bridge
corporation se encarga de la
construcción el banco chino eximbank ha
concedido un préstamo de 800 millones de
euros en el capítulo 8 del acuerdo
montenegro se compromete a renunciar a
la soberanía sobre partes de su
territorio en caso de incumplimiento
el nuevo gobierno ha heredado esta
situación el primer ministro se siente
atrapado
[Música]
y hay un dicho en nuestro país la deuda
es tu peor enemigo sin embargo me
encuentro en una situación desagradable
cuando me preguntan por nuestras
relaciones con china
el banco chino posee ahora una quinta
parte de la deuda de montenegro una
forma de que pekín extienda su
influencia en la región en el marco de
las nuevas rutas de la seda' iniciadas
en 2013
[Música]
el embajador chino en montenegro ha
rechazado todas las solicitudes de
entrevista este analista financiero pudo
hablar con él expresó su amargura por
las acusaciones contra su país
hay políticos que van a bruselas y dicen
china nos hizo esto china va a tomar
nuestro territorio el gobierno actual y
parte de la anterior se comportan como
si tuviéramos que elegir si hubiéramos
escogido la peor opción pero no teníamos
otra opción
tuvimos que suplicar los
tras seis años de gracia a montenegro
hizo su primer pago el pasado mes de
julio las obras se están terminando con
más de dos años y medio de retraso pero
la apertura al público aún no es una
realidad en los campamentos de la
empresa acs las preguntas no son
bienvenidas no se nos permite hacer
entrevistas para ningún medio de
comunicación o periódico
no tenemos permiso del gobierno de
montenegro en segundo lugar nuestra
empresa matriz en beijing nos ha dado
instrucciones claras de no hacer ninguna
declaración en esta fase del proyecto
richard para obtener información y
acceder a las obras de la autopista hay
que dirigirse a la empresa de máx
principal sub contratista local de la
cvc la empresa china sigue enviando a
dos empleados para supervisar las
palabras de milo mujanovic coordinador
del proyecto debe máx
dime si digo algo que no debería decir
le pido que me controle
si dice algo malo tengo derecho a
dispararle
mírenme del puente
contract
en el contrato en 13 rbc y el gobierno
de montenegro el 30 por ciento de las
obras estaba reservado a empresas
locales y como ve max es la mayor
empresa local se llevó la mayor parte de
ese 30% en total más de 270 millones de
dólares pagados además la empresa nació
en 2007 un año después de la
independencia desde entonces ha sido
omnipresente
ahora ve max hace todo tipo de obras
hace dos o tres meses terminamos el
parque ve más
actualmente estamos construyendo una
escuela en podgorica que es una donación
de nuestra empresa
la escuela en construcción aquí está
financiada oficialmente por be max el
alcalde de podgorica reconoció que
fueron este hombre y su familia quienes
pagaron los 7 millones de euros
necesarios
ranko ivovic encarna la promiscuidad
entre la clase política montenegrina y
ciertos círculos empresariales el
presidente milo djukanovic y su séquito
solían reunirse aquí regularmente en el
café ivovic de podgorica hasta 2015
cuando el lugar fue destruido por una
bomba
rankovic no se menciona en ningún
documento oficial y algunos medios de
comunicación locales lo consideran el
verdadero propietario debe máx
[Aplausos]
max es una empresa que apareció de la
noche a la mañana y de repente b-max
ganó todos los concursos públicos
básicamente es un gobierno dentro del
gobierno de crear state in state el
proyecto de la autopista fue el contrato
del siglo para ve max un contrato en el
que desgraciadamente se olvidaron un
buen número de elementos a priori
esenciales sobre todo el suministro de
agua y electricidad otra omisión
sorprendente esta vía de acceso en la
principal entrada a la autopista desde
la capital ganancia adicional para demás
unos 34 millones de dólares
en conexión tráfico conexión parts
colección principal entre la autopista y
pad gorica todo este proyecto se hizo
público en marzo de 2019 en el informe
de gestión de demás y el contrato se
firmó en mayo del mismo año dos meses
después entonces como sabían que iban a
ganar la licitación
las acusaciones de connivencia fueron
rechazadas por el ex ministro de
transporte
la misma persona que firmó el contrato
con el crs
no me interesan los vínculos entre b max
y ciertos miembros del anterior gobierno
en el que yo era ministro sólo quería
que el trabajo se hiciera y se hiciera
bien óptimo
para el ex ministro de macs estaba
cualificado para el trabajo
y todo se hizo correctamente
nunca habría firmado ese contrato si
todo no hubiera sido validado de
antemano por todos los miembros del
gobierno por el parlamento todo es
conforme a la ley sólo después de estar
seguro de ello acepte firmar el contrato
como ministro con eso
se aprobó una ley especial antes del
contrato en ella se establecían
exenciones del iva las cotizaciones a la
seguridad social y los impuestos sobre
el combustible para la cvc y todos los
subcontratistas gritan a basso bitch
vice primer ministro encargado de la
lucha contra la corrupción considera que
se trata de una maniobra del gobierno
anterior para protegerse de las
acusaciones
ahora criticamos a los chinos hicieron
una oferta aceptamos esa oferta eso es
todo esto es culpa de nuestros
funcionarios y probablemente tenían una
razón de peso para afirmar esto podemos
imaginarnos cuál es esa razón no tiene
nada que ver con prioridades del estado
gobierno e interés nacional de atracción
en national interest o de alcance
definitivo noto una de las razones
oficiales para construir la autopista
era abrir el norte del país
milo sábato buratovich está encantado el
primer tramo se detiene a pocos
kilómetros de cola ching la pequeña
ciudad de la que es alcalde
[Música]
mismo veo a man star pibe
estamos muy ilusionados porque cuando la
autopista esté terminada nuestras
estaciones de esquí estarán a menos de
una hora del aeropuerto de foto erick a
una mañosa tremenda dale con hacer caer
otro no favorece
fácil acceso a una zona de esquí en
expansión al comienzo de los remontes se
están construyendo hoteles de lujo a
gran velocidad uno de los inversores
está en el lugar para ver el progreso de
la obra pero prefiere no responder a las
preguntas de los periodistas
disculpen tengo invitados tengo que irme
les dejaré promocionar la ciudad
decís vos que es el jefe del proyecto
este hombre se llama soran becirovic
pero su apodo es este millonario
se ha visto implicado en varios casos
inmobiliarios por sus vínculos con el
clan del presidente de cannabis la
primera autopista de montenegro que
supuestamente beneficiará a todo el país
de momento sólo será rentable para unos
pocos en el puerto de bar en el mar
adriático la gente está impaciente por
recibir los frutos de ese proyecto algún
día montenegro se enfrenta ahora a un
nuevo dolor de cabeza de dónde sacar el
dinero para completar la autopista y
conectar por fin el país de norte a sur
[Música]
hasta que reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar este y los
programas anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]